الوحيد المكرر بكل نواحي تقدم هي التغيير
والتطور فابتدينا عن طريق الكتابه وبعدين
انتقلنا للصور من الصور الى الفيديو ثاني
الابعاد واليوم عم نبلش نحكي عن موضوع
الفيديو اللي هو ثلاثي الابعاد اوبرس اللي
نحن مركزين فيه وبكل منصاتنا كوننا فيسبوك
ولا انستقرام ولا واتساب ولا حتى الاجهزه
الكويست اللي تابعه الابعاد دائما توجيهنا
هو طريقه او توجه المستخدمين
فمثل ام بي سي وانا على فكره انا من
خريجين وفخور
فاحتفل معكم من اهل البيت فكثير يعني
فسعيد بهذه المناسبه حتى الام بي سي كيف
كمان تغيرت بطريقه طرحه للمحتوى والتفاعل
مع الجمهور نحن اليوم نشوف
واجبنا انه نعكس اليات التفاعل وحتى
نوع المحتوى اللي نحن من منطرحه يكون
دائما مع هذا التركز كمان في السنوات
الاخيره لاحظنا
الذكاء الاصطناعي والارت كيف راح يغير شكل
السوشيال ميديا وهل احنا يعني راح نتحرك
للفيرش والميديا او راح يتغير شكل من
تواصل اجتماعي للتواصل المرئي او التواصل
اصطناعي ذكاء اصطناعي هلا الذكاء
الاصطناعي هو جزء نحن اساسي من كل شيء
بنعمله كونه طرح المحتوى للمستخدمين يعني
اليوم احنا بنسمع كثير من مستخدمين انه
كنت عم بحكي بموضوع وطلعلي الفكر هذا كله
جزء من
اليات وحسبه بتنعمل عن طريق الذكاء
الاجتماعي
بتعطي لكل مستخدم اكثر محتوى هو ممكن
يتفاعل معه او محتاجه بهذا الوقت وبنفس
الوقت للمعلنين يعني نحن بنطرح للمعلنين
الاعلان
اللي ممكن يرد لهم اكثر
فائده بوقت مناسب والذكاء الاصطناعي كمان
طرح لنا اليه انه نقدر نطرح او نجيب نسبه
من المعلمين اللي بتسابق ما كانوا يقدروا
يدخلوا على السوق الاعلامي يعني اليوم
بقاله او شخص معين ممكن يحط مبلغ بسيط
ولكن مع الذكاء الاصطناعي ممكن نوصل هذا
الاعلان للنخبه المعينه من المستخدمين
اللي بيحتاجوا هذا الاعلان فجزء اكيد لا
يتجزا من الياتنا اللي بنستعملها اليوم
هلا بالمستقبل اكون حكيت له تطوعات تانيه
يعني عن طريق الشات او الواتساب في اليوم
اليات وتطلق تطبق انه ممكن تكون عندك حديث
كامل مع
يطرح عليك اقتراحات بيعرف
انت شو بتفضل كيف بتحب تتعامل وبتتفاعل
معك هذا الطريق
العالم بيتطور فعلا بشكل سريع جدا في
السنوات الاخيره ومع ظهور الاعلام الجديد
نيوميديا ايه دور الفيسبوك والانستجرام
وهذه التطبيقات في النقل المعلومات بشكل
مختلف وايضا الحفاظ على صحه ودقه
المعلومات الدقه والاحصائيات شيء جدا
اساسي عنا يعني اليوم نحن نعكس اللي بصير
بالمجتمع بنعكس النسيج الاجتماعي فخلينا
نحكي مثلا كمثال رمضان رمضان القادم حاليا
طبعا في عادات وتقاليد تقام برمضان منها
خلينا نقول على ام بي سي استهلاك المحتوى
والمسلسلات والبرامج الترفيهيه والدينيه
والى اخره
النقاش والحديث اللي بيصير على هذا على
هذا المحتوى بصير على منصاتنا ونحن نميز
اللي ممكن نطرحها ممكن نعطي احصائيات
دقيقه جدا عن هذا الشيء فمثلا السنه
الماضيه
في رمضان
كان اكثر مرحله بنشوف فيها ذكر التعاطف
والحسن بالمحتوى في اخر يوم في رمضان
طرحت كلمه التعاطف فوق ال 14 مليون مره
ويذكر كمان انه احنا اللغه العربيه هي
ثاني اكبر لغه على منصه فيسبوك بعد اللغه
الانجليزيه
فلذلك واكثر نموة اسرع نموا فلذلك اليوم
نحن بنشوف يعني الاحصائيات اللي نحن
نطرحها مع اربعه مليون اربعه مليار مستخدم
اسراحيات
يوثق منها
فبنشوف يعني التعبير عن الحسن والتعبير عن
التعاطف ونحن كمنصه نشر هذه الاخبار تمام
تعكس وجهه النظر عن الشرق الاوسط وتعكس عن
الدين الاسلامي اللي يمكن بالغرب ما
بيتوقعوا انه يكون هذا الشهر
من هذا الطريق طيب احنا عنا دقيقه بس لهذه
الجزئيه لانه عندنا مفاجئه لضفين اخرين في
العشرين سنه المقبله لوين رايحين
تكنولوجيا الى اين ستنقلنا هلا اكيد
التوجه المعتمد عليه من كل الجهات انه نحن
حنكون ننتقل من انترنت الابعاد الى انترنت
الابعاد يعني الكون الانترنت تغمر
المستخدم بطريقه اكثر وتعطيه طريقه
للتفاعل اغنى من الموجوده حاليا ما حيكون
هذا استبدال الواقع
موضع يعني ولكن تغذيه او او دعم للواقع
فمنشوف خلال الخمس لعشر سنوات القادمه
فكره الماتيفرس والتفاعل مع الاليات
والسلع الالكترونيه اكثر واعطيك احصائيا
احصائيين اليوم بامريكا الجيمرز او اللي
بيلعبوا عن طريق الجيمز
ثلث المستخدمين الجيمرز بامريكا بيدفعوا
اكثر على السلع الالكترونيه من السلع
الموضوعيه هذا عم يصير اليوم فلذلك مع
خلال هالخمس او عشر سنين حنشوف دمج بين
الواقع
استاذ فارس ابقى معنا بس يعني احنا تكلمنا
اليوم انه نستضيف الوجوه التي مرت على
صباح العربيه خلال العشرين عاما يمكن مش
كلهم موظفين في قناه العربيه ولكن وجوه
ارتبطت بهذا البرنامج من اشهر ضيوفنا خاصه
في فقره التكنولوجيا اسمحوا لي ان ارحب
بحراره من القاهره الخبير التقني عبد الله
السبع ومن الرياض المؤثر والمهتم بالتقنيه
فيصل السيف اصدقائنا واحبائنا وضيوفنا
الكرام في صباح العربيه صبحكم الله بالخير
صبحكم الله بالنور والسرور اهلا وسهلا
[ضحك]
انا مروا علي يمكن تقريبا
انت مر عليك كل كل المقدمين البرنامج صح
هو انت الثابت
يسعد صباحكم طيب بشكل سريع احنا طبعا
نتكلم ونسترجع ذكريات ما حدث في قطاع
التكنولوجيا على مدى العشرين عام السابقه
نبدا معاك فيصل يعني كمان رؤيتك لابرز
ابرز او انطلاقا من ابرز ما حدث من تغيرات
في قطاع التكنولوجيا ما هي التوقعات
للمستقبل
جميل جدا صبحكم الله بالخير واعيدكم في
هذه المناسبه عسى دوم ايامكم خير وبركه
ولجميع العاملين والاعداد الاخت اشواق
الاخت خلود كلكم بخير الله يعطيكم العافيه
ويسعدكم لو تكلمنا عن عشرين سنه الجايه
حتلاقوا تبني اكثر لشاشات قابله للطير
حتلاقوا فعليا عندنا هشاشات اللي
لابتوباتها كانت لوحيه وموجوده حتلاقوها
بشكل جدا كويس وهذه هتسبب لنا تعدد
استخدامات اكثر ما عدا الواحد يحتاج يصير
جهازين نفس جهاز الجوال اللي موجود عنده
حتلاقوه ينطوي بشكل اقوى ولكن الشيء اللي
مرتبط بالذكاء الاصطناعي وهو اللي حيكون
في ثوره جدا كبيره استحداث النسخ
الكترونيه لنا كل واحد فيكم قاعد موجود
الحين في نسخ الكترونيه تتعلم من محتوى
السوشل اللي موجود عندنا وبالتالي هذا
المحتوى والتعلم اللي يصير فيه حينشئ لنا
نسخه تقوم ببعض المهام اللي احنا اساسا
نقوم فيها وتلاقوا هذه المهام اكثر قاعده
اديها لاله واحنا نتفرغ بحياتنا بشكل افضل
واحسن حتلاقوا ايضا فيه تبني بشكل جدا
كبير لا المحتوى الواقع الممزوج شريحه
ابتداء من اتوقع السنه القادمه بشكل مره
قوي الواقع الممزوج وش السالفه من نفس
النظاره هتلاقوا في اثراء واعطاء كم محتوى
اكثر فيمديني على طول وانا قاعد معكم في
الاستديو اشوف حساب مثلا كل واحد موجود
عندنا الامر حاليا موجود نظارات واقع
افتراضي زي كذا وواقع ممزوج الواقع
الافتراضي حيمكن وبكل بساطه انه احنا من
خلال لبس هذه الخوذ ننتقل الى عالم ثاني
يا بكل بساطه نشوف اضافه طبقات من
المعلومات تثري المحتوى اللي موجود عندنا
اتوقع كمان العربيه نفسها هتبدا تستثمر في
مساله المحتوى الطولي اكثر في البث
المباشر فحتلاقوا انه لما يكون عندكم
التقارير والاشياء اللي انتم تنتجوها
وتسووها بالعرض هتلاقوا ايضا مع الوقت
قاعد طبعا التحيه لكل الشباب اللي موجودين
حتلاقوا مع الوقت هذا المحتوى العرضي اللي
قاعد يصير قاعد يثرينا بشكل طولي وتلاقوا
عندكم الشاشات مو فقط في العرض ولكن فعليا
شاشه نفسها تصير عندكم بالطول هذي الشاشه
اللي موجوده بالطول حتستري كم كبير من
المحتوى وتساندكم واكيد لما نرجع لمحتوانا
الاساسي حتلاحظه المحتوى الاساسي ايضا
قاعدين تستخدموه بطريقه صحيحه ومنها العرض
والطول تساعد هتلاقوا ايضا اثراء
للروبوتات حتشوف انه في مسانده صغيره من
روبوتات موجوده عندكم
طبعا عبد الله السيف في مصر كيف عبد الله
السبعه عفوا كيف ترى العشرين سنه المقبله
في مجال التكنولوجيا
طيب واحده من الشغلات اللي الناس قاعده
تتكلم عنها المشكله انت طرحته علي السؤال
بعد استاذ فيصل لكن راح اجتهد بالاجابه
واكون يعني تلميذ نجيب له واحده من
الشغلات اللي الناس اتوقعها ان الجوال راح
يكون من الماضي نهائيا زي ما شغلات كثيره
في حياتنا اصبحت من الماضي لذلك المستقبل
راح يكون الاجهزه الملبوسه نتكلم عليه
الساعات النظارات وغيرها فلذلك الجوال قد
لا يكون جزء من حياتنا خلال خمسه الى عشر
سنوات قادمه طبعا هذا امر جدا صعب لكن
لازم نقدر نتخيل الحياه من دون جوال خلال
السنوات القادمه ايضا الذكاء الاصطناعي
راح يدخل بشكل اكبر كثير في حياتنا
السيارات ذاتيه القياده راح تقدر تنتشر
بشكل اكبر وايضا تقنيات التنقل ما بين
منطقه الى منطقه راح تكون مختلفه قد نشهد
الطائرات التي تتنقل داخل المدن يعني قد
يكون هناك حلول للزحمه باستخدام الذكاء
الاص الطائرات والانترنت مع توسع وجود
تقنيه ال 5 جي في حياتنا قد يكون هناك
وسائل نقل مختلفه تقلل من الازدحام داخل
المدن مثل الطائرات مثل السيارات ذاتيه
القياده وغيرها الذكاء الاصطناعي راح يكون
متواجد بشكل اكبر بكثير في حياتنا وخاصه
في المجال الطبي قاعد نشوف احنا ابتكارات
جدا كثيره تسهل على الناس امور مختلفه
تخيل انك راح يكون من الماضي انك تسافر
علشان
تعالج من مرض معين شفانا الله واياكم اي
مرض راح يكون من الماضي انك تسافر ليه
لانه الرجال الاليين موجودين بامكان اي
دكتور من اي منطقه حول العالم انه يتحكم
بدرجه الالي ويساعدك في مرحله معينه من
علاجك فتقريبا المستقبل راح يكون مبهر
بسبب ثلاث تقنيات اللي هي ال 5 جي وما بعد
الفايف جي الذكاء الاصطناعي والتقنيات
الملبو سه مثل الساعات والنظارات وغيرها
شكرا على كل هذه المعلومات المكثفه في
الواقع يعني حاولنا نركز على كل كلمه طيله
من القاهره الخبير التقني عبد الله السبع
ومن الرياض المؤثر والمهتم بالتقنيه فيصل
السيف شكرا لك واشكر ايضا معي في
الاستوديو فارس العقاد المدير الاقليمي
لمتا فيرس شكرا لوجودك معنا شكرا